-"A Very Punchable Face" --
how did you come up
with this title?
-Just, like, looking in the
mirror, kind of being honest.
-Come on. I --
-I got a lot of --
-As a friend and as an elder
statesman, I don't like this.
I don't want
anyone punching your face.
And if someone did,
I would get your back.
-Well, thank you, thank you.
That was also
a real concern of my parents
when I told them
the idea for a title.
They were very concerned
that it would more of
an invitation
than a description.
But people --
I've heard it from a lot of --
I've heard it from a lot of
friends that were like --
Like, in a nice way,
but were kind of like,
"You look like a little --
There's some punchable
elements there."
-I will say, it's a fast read.
It's a really funny book.
If you don't even get to
the reading part,
the chapters are funny.
Can I just go through
some of these chapters?
-Please.
-Here's one I liked.
This chapter is called "Oops, I
Fell Asleep in a Graveyard."
-Yeah.
-Oh, and I love this,
'cause this was
"The Time
Jimmy Buffett Saved My Life."
And then I had a question,
'cause I go, "Wait.
Oh, he means --" And then you
put, in parenthesis,
"(And I Don't
Just Mean With his Music)".
So there's a story there.
-There's a story of him
saving my life, yes.
-Yeah. But I was like,
"Oh, I think what
he's talking about
is something --
He heard a song,
and that changed his life."
But he actually -- It's --
These stories are great.
You stole a photo from
Bill Murray's house.
Can we talk about that
on the show?
I can edit this out
if you want me to.
-No, no, no, no, no.
I'm so mortified by it
and I kind of --
I kind of put it in
the book as a confession.
You know, I believe
Mr. Murray, also Catholic,
so I hope he understands
the concept of
confession, penance,
forgiveness.
But I was --
When I was a writer at "SNL,"
I was at his house.
It was a Christmas party.
And my friend and I
were walking around, like,
with our -- you know, like,
starry-eyed that we were there.
And we were, like,
wandering the house,
because everyone
was all over the place.
And we, at some point, passed,
like, a box of stuff that --
And it was just like
we looked in the box,
and there were
all these photos of
Bill Murray
and Richard Pryor together.
It's Richard Pryor, like,
putting Bill Murray
in a headlock.
And it was,
like, such a cool photo.
And there were like 10 of them.
And it truly looked like
he was throwing them away,
I swear to God.
And I was like, "He's not gonna
miss one of the 10
that he's throwing away, right?"
And so I was like,
"I got to -- I'll --"
I was like, "I will --"
It felt like not stealing.
It felt like one man's trash
is another man's treasure.
And I think now,
as a person who finds treasure
full time with
a metal detector,
I'm coming from
that perspective now.
-I understand.
You know, I take it back.
I agree. You're so right.
Colin, when we have
our guests on the show,
we want to know if there's any
charities or organizations
that they'd like to talk about.
And you chose this organization
called REACH.
-Yeah.
-Would you like to
talk about that
and just tell me what
that's about?
-Yes, I would love to.
So, I went to this --
I got into this high school
that was in Manhattan.
I grew up on Staten Island,
and there was this school
I got into called
Regis High School
that is a free school.
It's a really good
academic school,
and if you get in there,
there's no tuition.
They started this program,
REACH, and what it does is --
it is basically a boot camp
from 5th to 8th grade
for kids who are
economically disadvantaged
from all of
the boroughs of New York.
And it helps get them
extra training
and help, intensively,
in the summer
and also throughout
the school year
to basically bridge the gap
that exists
for a lot of kids in New York.
It's super-effective.
So many of the kids get into
great high schools, great
colleges, have great careers.
And it's like -- It's just a --
They do such a good job.
And I just -- For me,
education was the way out,
and I think that's such a great
way up for everyone in New York.
-Thanks for doing that and
thanks for talking about that.
And congrats on the book.
-Thank you.
-My man, Colin Jost.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is awesome, buddy.
I can't wait to see you in
person, hopefully soon.